these are just a fraction of the 23
million flowers 1800flowers.com needs to
get from Farm to florist to customer for
Mother's Day with 10 of the annual
revenue on the line there's little room
for error it's the company's biggest day
for floral sales it is our Super Bowl
this distribution center in New York
City will see 10 000 of those Mother's
Day orders it's just one of the
thousands of facilities and independent
florists the company depends on to get
fresh flowers to customers Nationwide
we visited the company's busiest Hub to
understand the complicated Logistics
behind floral's biggest day of the year
this is the economics of 1800flowers.com
in the 1980s flowers were typically
purchased at a Neighborhood Grocery
Store or a local florist like this one
when you have something to say Laura
party can help you say with style but in
1986 that New York florist purchased a
toll-free number setting in motion a
transformation of the industry just call
on it or visit our stores when we
acquired the 1-800 Flowers number we
became a national business overnight the
company grew into a large network of
florists across the country just call
the number and it would figure out the
details and then came the world wide web
in the 1990s the floral industry was one
of the first to go online with 1-800
Flowers leading the pack we can take
care of that right now with America
Online we can yeah we can send your mom
flowers they're very Cutting Edge in
technology and online technology I would
consider them a leader as an e-commerce
company as a research analyst Linda
boltonweiser has covered 1-800 Flowers
for over a decade the floral network is
key to the business
and sort of standardizing the brand to
be able to advertise is is really part
of what they did to Pioneer the industry
better call 1-800 Flowers today the
company brings in two billion dollars in
annual revenue and with more than 5 000
florists in its Network holiday
Logistics are pretty complicated
preparing for Mother's Day is one of
those things that really gets our blood
going after a customer places an order
online it can be sent to a few different
places a farm a distribution center
owned by the company or one of the
Network's local florists where and how
orders are fulfilled depends on the type
of product and the location of the
customer getting the flowers to the
right recipient is more complex than
people think it all starts at a farm
like this one where flowers for the
holiday are harvested in May every year
the company relies on its own data to
forecast what types of flowers they'll
need planted preparation for a major
holiday like Mother's Day really began a
year ago when we would work with all of
our suppliers to say here's what we're
thinking of Designing how does that
match your growing Cycles the company
Imports flowers from all over the world
including California Ecuador Holland and
Thailand roses are the most popular for
Mother's Day the company expects to
deliver 10 million in 2023 at The Farms
flowers are cut sorted by type and color
and packaged for shipping the hardest
part keeping flowers alive and looking
fresh some customers have complained
that their orders arrived looking worse
for wear this is how they came
flowers were dead the company says that
customer experience is its number one
priority and that when it might miss the
mark it works with urgency to rectify
the situation quickly and to ensure the
customer is 100 happy with the
resolution
but the most important thing to avoid
those dead flowers in the first place
keep them cold including on refrigerated
trucks that cart the flowers all over
the country the faster you can get that
cut flower down to about 33 34 degrees
and then maintain that temperature you
suspend life and you can really extend
the vase life that a customer therefore
gets
the flowers are kept cold through
transportation and a rival at
distribution centers like this one in
New York warehouse manager Isaiah Brown
and his staff are preparing to receive
hundreds of thousands of flowers more
than double what they usually get when
the product comes in for the week of
Mother's Day we want to get it in as
late as possible so it's that as fresh
as for our customers which means all of
the Mother's Day prep has to happen fast
the staff here almost triples to prepare
for The Rush the flowers are unpacked
and processed it's very important that
we strip bottom leaves so that those
leaves when the flowers are cut and put
in the buckets are not submerged in the
water
cutting these stems at an angle allows
water to flow to the heads of the
flowers after flowers are processed
they're returned to the cooler room
designers pop in and out to pick out
flowers for their Arrangements this team
in New York will make a couple thousand
bouquets every day for the week of
Mother's Day to take any matter from a
few minutes to 15 minutes it all depends
on the occasion and the type of bouquet
we're talking about when the designers
finish most of the arrangements will be
loaded into trucks like this one and
delivered to the customer's door on the
same day
sometimes other gifts like Teddy Bears
or chocolate covered strawberries or
fruit bouquets are delivered with the
flowers that's part of the company's
bigger strategy to become a One-Stop
gift shop where customers can also order
from Harry and David or Sherry's Berries
they would like to be known as the
premier online gifting Marketplace in
fact 45 percent of the company's
business is in Gourmet Foods and gift
baskets business boomed during the
pandemic as people stayed home and sent
gifts online but as the world came out
of lockdown and an economic downturn
loomed both revenues and profits
decreased flowers are considered an
ephemeral gift meaning you can't
actually use it or consume it it's just
for beauty and enjoyment and so in a
recession that tends to be the gift
class that falls off first inflation and
Rising labor and Supply costs have also
affected the company competition has
blossomed too with companies like books
Urban stems and farm girl flowers
entering the 12 billion dollar floral
gifting Market food delivery services
like doordash and ubereats are also
getting in on the action we work with
many of them even though they also
compete against us e-commerce gives the
ability for people to get into your
category relatively easy it doesn't
replace the 50 years of experience that
we bring to the table to keep an edge
McCann is once again looking to emerging
Technologies in April the company
launched an AI generated poem composer
that's powered by chat GPT I see
opportunity to grow exactly as we are
now but I know that technology is going
to change things and will look a lot
different than we do five years from now
thank you